uh see you can you can continue the rest
second part thank you okay sounds good
yeah
uh i hope you guys had fun in the first
part and now we'll come to some beats
and talk about some like uh specific
results in the second part
so or like without further let's
directly start with two pair zero sound
games
we first started we start with a very
basic setting where we're gonna know the
transition and rewards so we know
everything and uh we already know like
this direct combination is not very good
way to compute an algebra but to
what is a good way so first let's try
the reinforcement learning way because
this is like a sequential
problem
so we should use a lot of reinforcement
and text links to this problem
in particular what are we going to do is
uh we first
we're going to still like use a standard
way where we can define the value
in terms of states and state action for
market policy and
basically there are some as you hear
about you can basically prove a nash
equilibrium strategy for a markup game
is always a market policy and in
particular because it's marvel positive
we can define the value for
for each state at each step and also for
each state action pair at each step
and then we will have this development
optimal equation
so i i guess dylan definitely introduced
the development and automatic equation
this morning for standard mdp so we'll
see what's the major difference
the first step is uh is about the value
of
q value
and address h starting at which is
denoted as a cumulative reward starting
at step h and the state s action ap
which is equal to the immediate reverse
and expectation of the value in the next
step which taking expectation over s
prime is the snack states sample random
change distribution this part is
absolutely the same
so the major difference is in the second
part where second part
in mdp all we have is v star is equal to
the max of a taking action over a which
is if you have single player and
killstar s8 here because we have two
players so we're doing a one is trying
to maximize the other is trying to
minimize so we can see here is kind of
like a for each states at each step
we're kind of solving a
normal form game for each state and and
step so it's kind of like a
matrix game we will find a min max
strategy that is uh the mixed strategy
for for action at this particular stage
time
and the stack
this is min max over probability
distribution over a and probability
distribution over b and this is
quadratic form uh this bilinear form for
the for the q value function close
direction function
and this is also equal to just equal to
not equivalent value of your q star
so we see when conditional when you fix
some state s this q value becomes a like
a matrix game they know the matrix in
and we can compute the value and we
compute the match strategy which the
national energy just becomes the
strategy of the optimal policy and
natural value will become the value v
star
is this part clear
so so what i want to say is uh if you
inspect the balance of automatic region
the only difference is now replace the
max by mean max and everything else is
the same
so this gives us a very good way a very
easy way to directly compute a natural
equivalent that is we just use the
belmont optimal equation and do dynamic
programming okay so when we call it
nashville
just to be consistent with the name in a
markov division process but it's
basically just
which is copying the bellman automatic
equation so what we are doing is uh
we're gonna start from the very last
step at h plus one because we're in the
episodic setting we assume the game
always stops at the step h so the value
at h plus one is always equal to zero
then we just do the belmont optimal
equation we first have v star h plus one
and we're going to use the domain
optional equation to compute the v
kill star h
and then we're going to use the q
storage to compute the
match strategy and then use the last
strategy to compute the match value
which become a v star pitch okay and
then this uh go backwards from the last
step to the first step and eventually we
compute the
nash strategy nash equilibrium policy
for the entire markup game as well as
the value or optimal value
this part is
almost the same as the microvision
process
and we already see like by by using this
structure of markov games we immediately
very easily get some algorithm which is
able to find like computer nash
equilibrium in this
known transition and reward setting in
some polynomial steps
well like previously in the this audit
direct approach even in this very basic
setting they kind of expand some
exponential steps to compute matching
so these are so basic and though we're
definitely interested to do a more like
complicated scenario so this is like a
known tnr no transition in the rewards
and we just briefly comment there are
also some other always not necessarily
just a nash value integration but also
like a nash key learning algorithm it's
also able to find a nash equilibrium
like by one environment 2013
and then we also have a simulator set
which is a slightly
difficult more difficult than this known
traditional reward scenario i guess you
know probably also cover this thing so
the similar setting is you can query any
state action
pair and you're going to immediately
receive the rewards at the next step
so this uh this is like something more
stronger than our interaction oracle
and uh so basic strategy for solving
those settings like similar setting is
that you're just going to call it all
the state action pair uniformly and then
your sample averaging to estimate this p
and r and pnr transgender rewards as
long as you have enough samples you
you're going to estimate this pr very
accurately then you can just do some
standard like a nash mesh value
iteration or nash pure learning and
you're going to learn in particular
there are two work like giant heart and
soul at all they consider variance of
national value iteration and not secure
learning and they will
accept some simple complete guarantee
for this similar setting
finally we
this talk will focus on more like the
practical setting of people also called
exploration setting basically the
biggest difference from a similar
setting is the agent no longer able to
choose any states so
we have to start from initial states and
asian is only allowed to take action
this is like a 100 percentage satisfy
our interaction protocol and so
in this scenario we actually need to
trade off exploration versus
exploitation and this will be our focus
today
just to recap our interaction protocol
is uh like we start on some initial
states and uh tuitions take some action
simultaneously and the most agenda
receive the rewards and environment
change the next step okay so this we
we're never gonna like uh pick some
states we're gonna change to we're only
going to pick actions
and also to complement what we some of
the
discussion we have in the
in the last session um
so we we actually have this is like this
is this uh this is a protocol like uh
tuition is playing the games but
during the during the process like what
i call training but basically during the
process we try to find a nice
equilibrium or trying to compute a nice
equilibrium even in this scenario for
like
only only observing trajectory we are
let's for now like assume we allow this
to centralize uh
solver that is so we allow we have a
centralized player which is able to
control two player which could be kind
of like they can tell the first player
to do something and they can tell the
second player to do something and they
will
do something listen to them and
collab together to like learn the
natural equipment like
during this learning phase it's okay
like
both players collaborate they kind of
they review everything they talk
everything
and in the later we'll talk about some
decentralized algorithm which does not
necessarily need that kind of
communication
okay
so in order to talk about this
interaction process we come to the the
biggest difference between reinforcement
learning and supervised learning i think
dylan covered this in the morning a lot
i will just be very quick about this
part so just uh quickly through
supervised learning is all about
we already collect a lot of samples in
the very beginning and then we just use
this sample to learn some
predictor
well in a reinforcement one big thing
difference is like we need to have some
interaction so we need to have and take
action and click policy which will
influence the samples we're going to
collect so this is a open this is a
closer loop
so whenever we talk about some actions
taking actions and we always talk about
some trade-off between exploration
versus exploitation this is the same for
microphone
also for mdp also for bandits for
contextual bandwidths
and the the only difference is like
from the connection benefits and venice
through mdp and micro premiums
there are some naive strategies like
epsilon greedy which is uh okayish for
bandits and connection bandits give you
some t2
3
2 3 regret but it's kind of terrible in
the this sequential scenario in either
mdp or not of games which will require
some exponential number of samples to do
exploration in the worst case that is if
you do this exploration strategy you you
will increase some
some sample conversion universities
which is expansion in in horizon length
h
so we all know like
one simple fix for that is we will use
an alternative strategy that is called
after confidence fund which lines the
very core of like designing all the pro
efficiency reinforcement algorithm for
like all the simulation settings and
multiples instead
i will just skip about what is the ucb i
assume you already learned this from
dylan's talk
so this comes to our first algorithm and
how we're going to fix the original nash
value solution to
to address the exploration setting
which you can think this is uh like some
counterpart uh like uh some counterparts
of the ucb vi you know has talked about
this morning so basically uc dvi is a
very traditional plus some bonus used to
be and this optimistic match vi is you
can think it's a option nash value
iteration with some optimism or with
some bonus
let's just spend a little bit more time
being like looking at this algorithm on
what what it does
so we'll still remember the bellman
automatic equation the first step is
more or less the same except we we kind
of we adding a beta and minus beta so
this this is because we kind of we
maintain upper bounds and more lower
bounds
um it's called optimistic um
because optimism is a way we're going to
do exploration but here we have two
agents so we're going to make sure it's
no it's not only optimism for the first
agent but also optimism for the second
agents
because the second engine is trying to
minimize so we also need to maintain a
lower balance so that's why we have both
operands and lower bounds
and the first step is just doing them
transition and the plus bonus and minus
bonus for upper bounds and lower bound
respectively and the other difference is
instead of taking some expectation over
the transition
which which we can do in the scenario we
know the traditional works but here
because we're only learning strong
trajectories
so we no longer have exact change in
rewards we're going to estimate it so
we're going to use this empirical
estimation of the transition
to replace the true transition in our
estimation the empirical estimation of
the transition is just the the the ratio
of the counts
like how many times you'll observe this
sequence of sab as prime and divided by
how many times you observe the sequence
of sap
the key different step is uh
remember in the nash equilibrium uh in a
in a bellman observatory equation what
are we gonna do is we we we know we only
have one single q value and we we can do
just a computer nash match policy of
that single q star and we're going to
return some policy and we use that
positive computer v value
however now we have upper bounds and
lower bounds
and
so one trick
so we kind of like uh just come back to
the the very center point we're going to
talk about here uh we actually use
so-called cross-court equilibrium
instead of nash equilibrium um in this
uh
this algorithm the main reason is we can
still use nash equilibrium to come
through the natural equilibrium of
aquaponics
but the problem is computer naturally
now this is a become a general sound
so although this is a zero-sum game but
because we're maintaining upper bounds
and lower bounds so we have two version
of value and this will become like a
general something in in our algorithm
and which we all know like finding the
nash equilibrium of general sum and it's
ppd heart which is compositional
inefficient so that's why we replaced
this general sum by
by cross-court equilibrium which can be
computed very efficiently by linear
problem and this technique is introduced
in shia
and after that then we just use the cce
the policy ccc and cross-court
equilibrium policy to
collect the inner product with the value
and we got to do that
the remaining thing is basically natural
equilibrium and the main thing is
basically about autonomic equation
see
so eventually these bonds are going to
be
quite narrow and
the game will be approximately zero sum
right uh can you
will that help can you then you know
maybe
switch at some point to calculating an
approximate nash equilibrium
uh
i think this you can ask uh custis i i
don't know whether some structure like
if like in general something with the
tool provided or closed whether we can
compute them efficiently probably causes
a better answer
but on the other hand also cce would
work like in a proof world and also the
cc would work is uh
if if if you know a lot more about game
theory you should know like in in two
players there are some things like if
you compute the
okay so if as you said eventually the qr
value are going to converge to a same
value or very close value and if if
eventually for in this idea scenario if
the qr code equal kilo orbital then a cc
we compute and if we connect
um like break the dependence like make
them independent it will just become
non-natural
what i'm saying is the marginal
distribution for the cce is actually a
natural equivalent for two pairs or
something
so this is like underlying reason where
we can replace notch by cce and without
oxygenation we can still eventually
require magic
so
in this algorithm you're just trying to
overcome the fact that you don't know
the probabilities
yes uh right uh this is uh okay yeah i
should also be a little bit so you're i
guess you're asking like we should also
don't know the rewards
right
yeah so and this is like a common common
thing in the reinforcement for
simplicity uh uh
just just because typically
like learning transition transitions
like for each state action pair you have
a x-dimensional probability distribution
you need to learn while for reward is
like for sab you only have like one
scalar to learn so learning reward is
kind of like much easier than than
learning transition of course the
algorithm can also be applied to
learning rewards like you just replace
this r by a hat and use empirical
average to ask in our head and
everything will go through
right and then if
you had exactly
you knew you knew r
and the probabilities would it be
equivalent to this nash value iteration
or
um
i guess if you know r and you know pi
then you make the
you may make this a bonus to be zero
then is it exactly equal to
not in the
natural iteration
good good questions so just to emphasize
some main techniques first we use the
empirical average to estimate the
transition probability and then we
maintain both upper bounds and lower
bounds and then we use the cc instead of
nash just to
to avoid some compositional hardness and
but this is suffice in a two-player
zero-sum game scenario
and this is our guarantee for these
options in natural iteration
um so we say with high probability
options in nashville equation we'll find
epsilon nash equilibrium of the markov
games in the following number of
episodes which is h cube as a b over
epsilon squared
and h is a the horizon of the game and s
is the number of states a b is the
number of actions for each each player
and epsilon is like the tolerance of a
high accuracy we want to find a nice
equilibrium
so now we have some algorithm basic
algorithm we already have that is able
to find actual epsilon natural
equilibrium
in polynomial timeline samples so i
think this would should be considered as
some equivalent of ucbdi which is able
to now dealing with some exploration
setting in markov game and it should
also be considered some like
basic results
and on the other hand we can also spec
like inspector what is the timeliness of
these results in particular we can prove
our information theoretically lower
bounds which is uh hq s
max a b
over epsilon squared now we'll talk
about this lower bounds because the
lower bound is like a much
it's kind of lower than upper bound so
this is actually very easy to prove we
can think of a very simple scenario
where
my opponent is like just a dummy player
he only has one action so in this
scenario my opponent is not affecting
anything i'm just playing a markup
divisional process and the markup game
should be harder than my provisional
process and uh
in my computational process we already
have h cube as a
foreign so this is basically just a
directly extended microvision plus lower
bounds through the smallhold game lower
amount
so
[Music]
um sorry um so what do you mean when you
say with high probability and what uh
typically prevents this from
finding the epsilon nash equilibrium and
um
um in this many episodes
prevent by
you mean what happens in a low
probability case
uh yeah and what what's typically the
problem that
we kind of we always estimate this
transition by a sample average there's
some low probability of this so this
average like
does not concentrate to the true
true transition and where you kind of
have a very biased destination so this
high probability means like always
probably one minus data and the episode
is going to only depend on log one over
third half
i kinda like the simplicity that
highlighted
is this theorem for there are some
things yes
i'm focusing on two pairs here sometimes
right now
okay so
this reads some this is set up some
basic results but this also raised some
concerns or with some like
further questions do you want to
understand
the first one is realize there are some
unique challenges that does not exist in
a singular reinforcement learning but
exists in the multi-reinforcement that
is what we have been talking about some
centralized algorithms
decentralized algorithm
so our optimism very large value
solution is a centralized algorithm
because that requires you to maintain a
value function for for this qr bar and
qr code basically you need to have a
centralized solver
and help with both player to solve this
cc of
of of this kyogre and colorbar and then
cc is like a correlated policy so you
have you also need a centralized server
tool to like instruct the base player
how to play the policy to collect data
however on the other hand we in practice
a lot of times we prefer decentralized
algorithm decentralized algorithm uh has
a lot of meaning in like distributed
optimization probably has some different
meanings so here in this login
reinforcement learning people usually
mean decentralized algorithm by means
that each agent just ran some algorithm
themselves without talking to other
players
they might initially say oh all of us
going to run the same algorithm but
during the during the execution they
never they never like communicate with
others so as if it's like in a single
agent scenario
as as if they're just running mdp
so decentralized algorithm has a lot of
advantage over centralized algorithm
it's easier to implement because you
only need to implement a single asian
algorithm then everyone run a single
agent algorithm you're already
guaranteed to find match equipment which
sounds like very good
and it's also more versatile because you
just care about yourself it's kind of
also agnostic to the actions of other
players
and then finally it's uh faster and it's
uh
require
less communication
so the states shared by both agents
inaudible games it's not necessarily in
the algorithm so so it's like a fully
observable
setting so the online stage is observed
by everyone
okay
and uh
so this is a first challenge can we
design some like a decentralized
algorithm
uh we also know decentralized algorithm
just means everyone runs
runs their single asian version of
algorithm but they kind of at the very
beginning they say all of us are going
to run this particular situation
algorithm so it's not no regret learning
it's just decentralized algorithms
the second one is
we also want to uh we're also kind of
interested in bypassing the estimation
of the q value why we want to see
something like that and this is because
uh
most of first most single relation
reinforcement learning actually relies
on as many qstar or the q value like no
matter q learning value iteration or
model based algorithm eventually they
rely on like computing the value
function even like a lot of functional
approximation algorithms relies on like
estimating the curve
however we know in markov games and the
biggest thing is the q value function
now has entry s a b
sorry it should have h s a b amphibious
so for each
step and each state
it has
it is a matrix game of size a b so it
has a times b entries to estimate this
value function you require something
order at least a b samples
however we notice already notice the
lower bounds incremental lower bounds we
have is not a times b but it has a max a
b
this says something like you you want to
if you want to develop some algorithm
that is able to like bypass the the
current upper bounds already achieved by
magic optimization nashville iteration
and to achieve this lower bounds the max
a b
you you need to develop some new
mechanism so that you can by passing the
estimating q value but you can also
learn in that match equator
so the main question here is can we
design some decentralized algorithm and
also achieve the optimal sample density
which is the max instead of a a times
question so far no
so we first consider whether this is
even possible in the like a simple game
like for example we already know normal
form of game is a special case of markov
game
so we first consider normal form again
it is the answer is yes actually we we
do have an answer for this single sound
the answer is just everyone ran no
regret algorithm like
the xp3 like a follower of rage layer
for other bandits
then what you're going to guarantee is
uh in a couple of zero-sum setting
if you're gonna marginalize the both
pairs of policy and do some average
and then this this product policy is
eventually going to converge to the nash
equilibrium
and furthermore because each player is
only running no regret algorithm so he's
running xp3 and he don't really care
about what opponent is doing he don't
even care about how many actions
opponent have so the final sentence is
going to set skill with a plus b or mad
max safety which is a
same thing okay
so in the normal form game we do have
some guarantee like this
so this comes with a question like okay
if you want to achieve that why not just
run no regret algorithm for macro games
no regret algorithm for microphone is
defined in this way so we kind of like
to require for every iteration t
and uh
our policy a joint value of a joint
policy is going to compete with the best
policy in inside okay
max pi 1 and inside and we require this
regret to be some sublinearity
so as we already mentioned in earlier in
the earlier session we already know that
we cannot miracle games do not allow
efficient no required algorithm no real
learning algorithm so just be more
specific here what do we really mean we
mean the existence of the part-time
algorithm another rare algorithm and
like satisfy this guarantee will implies
the existence of quality time algorithm
for learning parity with noise which is
a known like a
conditional
which is a
game which is a problem which already
conjecture to be hard in competition
and later on very recently okay this is
some working process um but but working
progress but we will probably because
this works soon and we actually we can
further strengthen this law and without
the hardness result to statistical
results so we can actually say no regret
learning microphone is at least as
as hard as learning best markov policy
in partial observable markov position
process okay
we all know like partial observable
multiplication processes like simulation
scenario but involve partial
observability and uh there are a lot of
like conditional harness and specific
harness the reason we can do that is
if we no regret learning with in mark of
gaming essentially you allow your
opponent to play anything
like even with
your opponent research remarkable set of
market policy they kind of like play
some
they can just play different amount of
policy at every tuition eventually you
play a mixture of minor policy and the
this just makes things has a lot of
correlation eventually become very
similar to point
okay we kind of already emphasized a
little bit about this uh key difference
between our mark of the end and the
original thing
however on the other hand we also know
no regret learning is only like a
sufficient condition for finding a
natural equilibrium it's not a necessary
condition for finding nash equilibrium
so
although we cannot do the
algorithm we do recently have a solution
for like running some something similar
to another algorithm but it's not an
autograph
but it actually has some good properties
similar to no regret algorithm
so this is the algorithm we introduced
in 2020 and later we kind of simplified
the algorithm so this is the way we
present it in the newspaper about this
algorithm we call vlearn
we call require relearning because it's
actually very similar to q learning
which securing is a single vision
reinforcement in the algorithm and
performs some
incremental updates to the q value
here v learning is also performed some
incremental updates to the v value
but one very important thing is as we
said earlier we want to bypass the
estimation of q value function so here
our vdw does not asthma kill value
function it only estimates the v value
function
let's look at the algorithm
so the algorithm is basically uh quite
simple we can just describe in this many
lines we have uh
we kind of go first for episodes
playground one to capital k it's just a
standard for reinforcing learning then
we also take steps from h1 to capital h
in every step
we first take an action
that is sampled from the current policy
i maintained
and then i observe rewards and the
states this is just a
standard thing which i execute a current
policy and i
the rewards and the states i collect
data
then the key part is how we update the
policy and value
first one is just counting we're kind of
like adding accounting of uh
i visited as edge to to just to be plus
one
next thing is the key
of the equation that is i update the v
value equal to one minus alpha fraction
of the previous v value
plus alpha fraction of the new updates
that i observed that is the immediate
reward i received and the value of the
next stage plus some bonus
so far this is the same as the q
learning without confidence balance but
the only difference is like this is
replaced p value by v value
but one major
drawback of replacing q value by v value
is like we know by q value it
immediately instructs me what is the
policy i'm going to play because i can
inspect the q value either i play greedy
positive for q value or play some nash
equilibrium of the true value
however for for this uh multiplication
scenario for this uh
viva learning algorithm if we only have
v value then we don't know what is the
policy we're going to play so that's why
we need to use some adversarial banded
algorithm in this scenario so we're
going to maintain adversarial benefit
algorithm for every state at every step
s and h
so what we're going to do is we just
feed in the action i just sampled from
this pie
and i also feed in the immediate loss
which is a reward i immediately received
and then the value which is only on the
estimated value of the next step i have
i use this as a visceral loss feeding to
the banded algorithm so this battery
algorithm can exp3 can be near the same
can be followed right as leader
and eventually this benefit algorithm
gonna return me the policy and i will
use this policy as a policy for v for
for vlad
for for v learning
so this is a single engine algorithm i
want to repeat and the major difference
from the cuba this
major difference of this algorithm and
the q learning is uh we update on v
value and then we use a bended algorithm
to
update actions
and in fact the way we choose the
learning rate is exactly the same as q
learning
several properties about the b learning
algorithm first one is the single region
algorithm
second one is used adversarial bandit
algorithm as long as it satisfies some
weighted regret guarantee
so if we remove this archive tt it's
just a standard regret guarantee so now
we want to have some great ways to
regret energy which is also not that
hard to satisfy in particular follow the
logarithmic leader will satisfy this
property
and finally it has no regret guarantee
for each states with figure loss just
because we're running a regular
algorithm for each state
but i also want to emphasize there is
not a no regret algorithm for the
hallmark of game
it's only the no regret for each phase
and also with feeder space video loss
but not the no regard for marketing
it turns out this is sufficient tool for
us to get some good property for
for learning multi-user
motivation enforcement learning so our
setting is we just uh basically for both
asian around the learning independent so
this becomes a decentralized algorithm
because the dlna is a single simulation
algorithm so both agents just run a
singular algorithm so they don't need to
connect it they only need to talk with
each other
and therefore several benefits
subroutine we're going to use this for
the regardless leader
and this is a guarantee will prove with
um detention in 2020
we see in two players there are some
markov games
we run v-learning with follow the
wireless leader as a solo routine we'll
find itself
optimal nash equilibrium in the
following number of episodes
that is h to the fifth horizon to the
fifth and number of states and most
importantly we no longer suffer this a
time speed and complexity we only do max
a b or x on square episodes
so
we do achieve some unique uh reduced
result resolve some unique challenging
multi-reinforcement learning variant is
a decentralized algorithm that is able
to achieve the optimal the decoupled
like dependency on action simultaneously
the max av
and we also know this uh dependence on
the horizon may not be very sharp it's
h2 fifths so we'll
like
leave this to the future works to
sharpen this dependence on the horizon
any questions so far
i will just briefly summarize what i
have
talked for two-pair zero-sum scenario so
we introduced the nash um optimistic
natural value iteration the main it
mainly estimate this transition and it's
a centralized algorithm and it has the
sample capacity that is hq sab over
epsilon squared so it suffers from a
times b but it's very sharp in h
and there's algorithm i haven't talked
about that it's not sure learning which
is extending children into multigen
scenario which again like use very
similar techniques asking the killstar
and it also suffer this a times b
and uh h2 fifths
and now we have some new algorithm which
is uh motivated is also a single agent
algorithm but it's a design purely
motivated by the multigene scenario
trying to solve multiple challenge it is
a decentralized algorithm it also only
estimate the v-value instead of q-value
and achieve the sum of complexity which
has a max a-b
instead of a times b i mean
in this part it matches lower bounds
to summarize what i want to talk about
uh for the type of truth or something
questions we'll go for the general
examples
uh i guess general some games uh i will
be a little bit fast because we already
have a solid foundation for two player
games so for general some games the
major difference is now we have a set of
action for instead of just have a and b
we have a
m actions and action center for all m
different players
and because this is general sum games we
also have m different rewards which kind
of indicates the rewards for
each different player okay for ice
rewards
for ice player i have ice ice rewards
and then we also have general policy
that look at all the history of the
of all the past history of all the
action taken by other pairs and we're
going to take take some take some random
actions based on that we'll have a
marker positive which can depend on this
one
then we can define a value in the same
way which is a joint value a joint we
define a joint policy which is a
combination of all the policies of other
agents and we can define the value for
ice player
it's a summation cumulative rewards
summation of other rewards for the ice
player and if all players following a
policy path
this is a little bit repetitive i will
just be fast and i want to focus more on
my high level integration about the
multi-gen and general sound part
the first thing is we can probably
generalize the nash equipment to general
some nash equilibrium which is defined
again as no player has incentive to
deviate from hard current strategy
and we know this especially in the
special form we already know in even in
a special form of normal form of games
computing nash equilibrium in general
sum is gpa heart
which provides carcass
constantly so
so maybe we for general sum games we
want to
explore some others
notion of equilibrium for the sake of
conditional efficiency
so some other equilibrium we consider is
one is the coordinate equilibrium
which which uh which is a
coordinated policy instead of uh i think
people have been covered this a lot in
this uh
in this week and basically what i'm
saying is for mark of game we can also
define quality equilibrium and of course
query equilibrium and in the same
way so that we say for quality
equilibrium no player wants to debate
from her current policy
if she can still observe a simple action
from correlated policy well the
cross-court equivalence is she don't
want to deviate from policy if she
cannot observe that some production from
the chord process
and we have the basic relation which is
called true for non-form games but also
in mind of game that is nash equilibrium
is inside a quality equilibrium also
inside a coarse correlated equilibrium
and finally the although the natural
equilibrium is pretty hard to find the
quality equivalent like cross-current c
and cc can be solved by linear program
so it's some combination efficient
thing to solve
okay so we'll first talk about how we're
going to extend our first basic
algorithm that is the match value
iteration to the general sound setting
we record this is what we have for zero
something we maintain acrobats and lower
bounds and we compute the cce
so in general sum all we need to change
is uh
now instead of just a one copy of q
value we need to maintain our upper
bounds for
for the value of all players so we need
to maintain upper bounds for qri h
lower bound is not very essential but
but you can also maintain lower bounds
and the most important thing is i'm
going to change this cce
um this is a
subroutine to something i compute the
equilibrium of
the upper bounds on q1 up one then q2
around q3 to upper bounds on qm
so this is a multiplayer equilibrium
this equilibrium can be nash equilibrium
can be
correlated equilibrium can also be cross
quality equilibrium
the only difference is that nash
equilibrium is conditionally intensive
while the other one are not conditioned
and because this is the only pure value
at a particular state at a previous step
so these are all normal form games we're
just computing
uh nash equilibrium c e and cc for the
normal home games
so this gives a first basic results
which we by some direct extension of the
natural habitation into multi-gene
scenario we able to find the epsilon
nash c or cc based on like whether you
replace this equilibrium by nash
equilibrium or by ce or by cce
in a general sum games in this number of
episodes
this is h to the first s and the
product of the ai where ai is the number
of actions for each player or it's not
square
any questions for now
i guess you can imagine this is like
direct extension where you know
two-player setting this is like a b well
here we have we got a
product over here
sorry we actually have s squared here we
have additional dependence on s um
because the nash and cicc in general
something is not unique where you need
to pay additionals
so now we also receive something
a little bit undesirable
because we already observed the sample
capacitance of this basic algorithm
actually scale with product of ai
if all player has the same number of
actions this means the number of
sometimes someone capacity will be omega
a to the power of m this is the size of
joint action space but this is also
going to be grow exponentially with the
number of agents
so the main question here is uh can we
achieve some polym symbol condition so
which we should call this like cursive
multivisions
i guess most of you after listening to
the like the previous part of the talk
you probably can't really guess we
should have some answer to this
we again goes back to the look at the
simple normal form games
and uh we know in a similar convenience
we actually have for general sum for
general summonings if we run no regret
algorithm for all the agents
independently
we will have the uniform like the
average policy will eventually converge
to a cross-coordinate equilibrium
and sometimes that the actual scale is
the
max of ai that is the maximum number of
action of each agent instead of the
product of data
and similarly for course
for cross correlated equilibrium we
actually can also achieve similar thing
but the only difference is we should not
just run no regret algorithm but then we
need to run no swap regret algorithm
so overarching is slightly different
like no regret is kind of saying i need
to com computer against the
fixed action that is like action a
action b and the slow for grad is kind
of saying i need to compete against some
swapping of my policy that is for
example
for all the equations i take some action
a1
what if i just swap the action a1 to a2
and would that help like i want to
compete with all the possible swap of
the policy
and we will see and the slope regret is
actually a stronger guarantee for
regress so any algorithm achieved loss
to work with ram will achieve low regret
so for
if every player is running a no swap
regret algorithm
independently the average policy will
also convert your course quality a
commercial quality equilibrium
and the sum of quantity is just slightly
higher so i could um the max ai squared
so this gives your idea um we already
have four markov gaming we kind of have
some
equivalent version of no regret
algorithm is like this relearning so
when i just do this vlearning we record
this we're learning we have this
adversarial bandwidth
update subroutine so we can plug in this
adversary bending algorithm to be no
regret algorithm we can also plug in to
be no swapper red algorithm
so this immediately gives us
some
guarantees for v-learning with the photo
like
for finding cce and ce in the general
sum games
so beginning with follow the leader will
find the epsilon version of the
cross-courier equilibrium in this number
of episodes where we no longer have the
explosion of the we do not have a
product of action it no longer has curse
of notations instead of it only has max
i ai so the largest number of actions
and then we also have v learning with uh
this node's work regret algorithm which
is a photo like that leaders work
and you will find ebstrom version of the
cross-court equilibrium in this number
of episodes
so we note v-learning is actually a
decentralized algorithm that able to
break the curse of multilings
so finally i just want to summarize very
briefly about the sample competitive
relearning of the learning markup games
so this kind of gives us a complete
picture about what we can already know
like for two players there are some two
players zero somethings and multiplayer
generation things we have three
objectives nash cce and c
for two players there are some games we
able to achieve
for nash equilibrium we're only able to
do two players or something because the
general sum is the tpd complete so but v
learning is like a combination efficient
algorithm so we cannot do it
and in a two cell some settings we can
also do the max ai
for nash well for
for c and scc we can do both in general
sound and the only difference is for ceo
we only play one a vector that a is
equal to the maxim and for coordinate
equilibrium we need to play a square
which is slightly worse because we need
to have a no small forward algorithm
but we can find all the solution
concepts in the territory microphones
okay um
any questions till now
no questions i will just briefly go over
advanced topics
several topics i want to cover
one is about the lifestyle space i
believe dylan has talked a lot about
this
during this morning
so i will also briefly talk a lot a
little bit about this in markov games
i think the reason is also is it's not
very well developed in the multi-union
scenario yet but in a single region a
lot of work is doing that
so
it's the challenge is again the large
state space because we kind of so far
we're having focus on the temperature
setting where the number of states can
actually are kind of small and finance
so the strategy is basically we will try
to visit other visible states and learn
them directly
so
there exists a lot of theory for it
but what happened in practice is like
for example for starcraft
there are actually tons of states so all
each issue value of pixel can occur
each combination of value of pixel
represented as states and you can easily
compute the number of spaces like
10 to the 100
and all the tabular guarantees we get so
far has some linear dependence on the
number of states which definitely not
feasible in practice we cannot just
visit all the strings most in fact when
learning with
most players are not visited even once
so one strategy we need to deploy in
this setting is to approximate value or
function in a parametric setting uh by
some parametric class f such as deep
neural networks
and our objective here in the function
processing using so-called functional
product measure setting is to we would
like our learning algorithm to have some
sample capacity that depends only on the
complexity of the function class f
instead of the number of states as
whereas this can be like 10 to 100 or
can be infinite
so just briefly go over what exists uh
in this field first one is the linear
markov gains linear markov game is the
kind of extension of a linear amount of
decision process
which assume the transitional rewards
that both are linear
and in fact there is a shield how in
2020 prove
their existing algorithm we should able
to learn this linear amount of
games
with this number of episodes where
there's no dependence on number of
states inside it depends on the ambient
dimension d
the idea is
similar to what we have been already
presenting the nash value iteration and
with the only difference like replacing
the exact
updated equation by a least square so
it's kind of similar to in a single
single region setting where you can also
do linear function approximation you can
do least square value situation and here
is the same
and we also have some results of our
general function approximation which
kind of like extends the existing
results about the bellman in a way like
existing way like you know natural
iteration always maintaining upper
bounds and lower bounds but for general
function approximation without like
optimus closure that kind of strategy do
not work
in techniques so we need to develop a
little bit different style of
exploration strategy here the way we do
is so called exploited
style exploration that is uh
although we eventually want to learn the
natural treatment for both player but to
learn and we kind of we do it a similar
easy measure way we first fixed one
engine to be the main agent and the
other agent will be exploited so major
always playing optimizing large policy
well the exploiter is trying to play the
option is the best response to the major
so it's kind of exploited the weakness
of the mange and help it to learn
so it turns out in our setting this
seems like some something necessary for
a functional approximation and we're
able to
do some sometimes that eventually only
depends on the iterative dimension and
not on the like number of states and
this new dimension class is kind of
relatively very rich it includes like
tabular marketing smart pins with linear
functional approximation with kernel
function approximation also like with
virtual observation
but it's a but it has the same problem
as the
as the general function approximation
algorithm in the single region setting
it's also not kind of efficient
i will also talk a little bit about the
partial operability and which is also
something very interesting to work on in
multi-asian scenario
like uh in fact like a lot of
applications we talked about the poker
we don't observe what the heck what the
cars in opponent's pants and like
starcraft we always what what for we
don't see what is hidden on top and like
behind this forks
and we also have robot which may have
first first-person camera they don't see
what behind me
so it's very common in practice
but uh
it's also much harder to require agents
to maintain memories and infer based on
the entire history so there are a lot of
higher kindness results already in a
single human scenario and even in a
poland a lot of harness results so i
think the first basic setting people
talk a lot is uh it's a very simple
version of the game that's like it's
just a nice simple version but it's a
it's a super class uh sorry it's a
special class of markup game that is an
extensive home game but you put a
partial opportunity on it with a very
special case that is the imperfect
information extensive form games for
people who know this kind of model is
kind of also commonly studied in the
game theory literature uh it can be well
applied to poker game for example like
uh for the
library tasks and uh just like
and those uh poker box is the world
champion they actually use the solver
for
imperfect information extensive form
cream to solve some like
like abstract strategy
so there are a lot of earlier work on
this
improv information extensive form of
games
which the complexity actually written in
in terms of
epsilon how like how actually you want
to find nash equivalent and also a b are
the number of actions of both both
players and x and y are the important
thing this is like the most important
thing which is the number of infor set
information set they have for each
player
and we
there are like two class of algorithm
that are called objective mirror descent
and contextual and regret
regret minimization
so
so previously our previous results have
uh
did a lot of great work for both line of
algorithm they achieved this sample
capacity and the best one is achieved by
kuzuna so far they have x squared
dependence on info set and a y squared
depends on an input size
so what we have done recently which will
also be announced very soon we actually
can
have much sharper complexity
for optimism design style algorithm also
for cfr style algorithm we're able to
achieve the shortcut capacity that only
depends on linear on the input section
on x and y and this has to smash the
lower bounds
finally we also have like a partial
observable general partial observable
scenario which is not necessarily
extensive form game which is not
necessarily emission in terms of this uh
impulse stats
and the coin api and pro microgame is
like very hard if the observation
contains no information about states we
can easily prove a lower bounds like if
the state is completed if the
information observation has noticed no
information about states then basically
we were kind of
doing some control without observing
anything and that's that's not feasible
so what we can actually do
in very recent work is we can show in a
special class of general markov games um
if the observation contains some proper
information about the states then we can
design an algorithm that are able to
learn the epsilon equilibrium of this
partial observable markov game in
polynomial number of samples
i guess this is a just a very quick
taste of what kind of results you can
possibly achieve in the
advanced setting there are also a lot of
other topics that i haven't covered like
a further design
of decentralized algorithm we only
talked about one distinction area i
wasn't like re-learning but there also a
lot of other scenarios where like you
have tons of
agents you want to collaborate on some
joint objectives and you want to have
some centralized ex
training decentralized execution
and
some other topics like policy
optimization and also other notation of
equilibrium like psychologically in
general some things also micro potential
games all those are all like different
topics in multi-generation learning
today i don't have time to cover
okay finally i reached the conclusion
basically i just want to briefly reveal
what we have been talking about today in
this tutorial we're first to talk about
the formulation of
mark of games and the objective we want
to find a nice equilibrium and later we
want to find the cross-current equation
and
correlated equations similar very
similar to not normal normal form gains
but it's slightly with slightly
different definition
and then we talk about some direct
combination like very direct approach
which directed you some
[Music]
best response based approach of uh game
director algorithm combined with single
vision reinforcement algorithm why and
we kind of argued why this naive
approach doesn't work and then we talk
we already focus on the tabular markup
game scenario
both in both zero-sum gains and general
sound beams
we mainly talk about two algorithm which
is optimistic variation you can think
this is a direct extension of what we
have in the reinforcement learning civil
engineering reinforcement learning with
some adjustments
and
then validation uh v learning algorithm
which is like a very different achieve
some several unique properties like
decentralized l decentralized
learning algorithm and has a lot of
property similar to no regret although
it's not a no regard algorithm
and finally we talk a lot about other
advanced topics like function
approximation partial observability and
a lot of other topics
and hopefully after the tutorial you
will realize uh
actually except there's like a basic
setting like tabular a lot of advanced
setting is kind of like a lot of
a lot of results missing in the
multi-universe menu and there are a lot
of opportunities you can solve some
urban problems for this contributor to
this field
and that will conclude my talk and thank
you for listening to that
thank you thank you very much
any questions
one question i had a uh as a general
comment like so when i when i think of
uh
learning multiple people learning about
some unknown state of the world
like in innovation settings there's a
lot of considerations about do i want to
reveal the information i gathered as i'm
learning to other people and their
incentives along these lines so where
would these considerations fit into uh
the models that you presented today
because there seemed to be like a
training phase and the test phase in the
training phase almost there were no
incentives for information sharing but
it seems to me that there's you know
like in real world when you're learning
they're always incentives
um
i think this is also something which i
haven't talked about in the market so
yeah i think so today's focus uh
is more about just directly finding a
notch equipment on a course-coordinated
equilibrium and and
i think what do you talk about is more
like a online setting which is more
close to like no regret saying we
already know regret cannot work but
there might be some other things you can
work like you want to
against some
unpredictable opponents like possible
adversarial opponents and what is the
strategy you want to do in that scenario
and i think that's also a very good
question
i guess the major problem is that it's
very difficult for markov game
to admit
efficient solution for a lot of those
question formulations
but it's possible you can come up with
some formulations which which
so talk about some harness for design no
regard
learning uh
against channel like adversary but
what if we just restrict the
other server to be some marker policy
yeah as i said the restrictive adversary
uh visual appointment to my possibly do
not help
like because
if each round the opponent is played
like different marvel policy
and on average he's playing like normal
person
so you can actually uh so actually our
construction
[Music]
our proof like we show is for normal
components we show it for market policy
you actually can prove the lower last
year cost
okay thank you
any further questions
if not then thanks chi thanks for the
wonderful tutorial
i guess this concludes also the bootcamp
and thanks for all the speakers for
the uh great effort that they put into
preparing their tutorials and i'm very
grateful that they agreed to give those
tutorials and see you
next week at the reading groups and at
the all of the events that we'll be
having thank you very much